how you reject Nation
we are here to do the Barbie main trailer reaction
be a good doll and uh leave a like on this video
if you're excited for the Barbie movie also John
do you know how you're always like jealous of Paul
from heavy spoilers Channel you're like Greg you
talk with him so much uh man what's going on in
your conversations and I'm like no John leave me
alone it's my life shut up go away well get ready
to be more jealous John cause heavy spoilers and
I we have started up a podcast that is debuting
on his channel real spoilers today at another one
o'clock or two o'clock P.M Pacific Standard time I
don't know exactly know what time it is his choice
he's in control of our relationship subscribe
to his channel that's why he's doing this and
so I can send more subscribers his way what a
hey Barbie
can I come to your house tonight wow I don't have
anything they planned just a giant blowout party
with all the Barbies and planned choreography
in a bespoke song you should stop by so cool
diamonds under my eyes oh how fun
it is the best day ever and so is
yesterday and so is tomorrow and every day for now
what
existence
cold shower falling off my roof
and my heels are on the ground
oh my how beautiful this looks
you have to go to the real world
you can go back to your regular life or
you can know the truth about the universe
the first one the high heel you have to want to
know okay do it again that's a freaking stock
I'm coming with you okay
wow I love the look of the song it's
the real world Barb is afraid what's
going on why are these men looking
at me yeah they're also staring at me
this movie is not for you that's impossible if
this got out this could be an extremely weird
things for our world this is what catastrophic we
haven't played with Barbie since we were like five
years old oh my who's this for it's even more
Lego than Lego he's back in a box nobody else
I only have one ending get that
Barbie Mattel ideas live forever
just one appendectomy but I'm a man but not a
doctor can I talk to a doctor you are talking
to a doctor I need a clicky pen No a sharp thing
no there he is Doctor somebody gets security ugh
Holy balls all right well once again yeah I think
this movie does look at absolutely beautiful it
is a gorgeous looking film and we actually got
a very clear-cut sense of the plot this time as
opposed to the teaser trailers the teacher
trailers I still might have actually liked
a tad bit more just because there was such a
a Charming Oddity that still carries over to
here with the part of the movie that I'm a bit
concerned about how it might ultimately play
out is actually when they leave Barbie land I
I'm very I was very much drawn to everything
within Barbie land when they get to the real world
that's when it starts to look a little bit like
you know I feel like I've seen this kind of movie
before that version of it of stepping into the
real world it's like kind of reminds me of like
a lot of Christmas movies uh you know some people
a lot of people are liking this to things like
elf and there's like Santa movies like that it's
like they were like is that really Santa Claus out
here I still have a lot of faith in the filmmakers
and that was the only time in all of the mark
anymore I was like I wonder how this part of
it is actually going to go down and here's the
other part of my brain that is also clicking off
is I feel like there's a lot of this movie that's
very hard to communicate of what they're going for
within a trailer span that's why they probably
needed two teaser trailers and then a full main
trailer so that way they can get audiences
acquainted with this world and also whatever
weird tone this is because there is like two tones
I'm seeing here the big Studio film and then also
that Greta gerwick independent kind of movie as
well I mean this even ends off on what I I imagine
is the theme of this movie because there's so much
of these existentialism qualities to what Barbie's
journey is about questioning her reality and
questioning the world and wanting to learn more
uh where it says there's something at the end
about humans have a shorter lifespan but ideas
live forever I don't really know how that's going
to play into the Barbie character development I
get that for the concept of what Barbie is and
what Barbie represents I mean do you have any
thoughts on that I I'm curious I mean because
certainly it seems like Barbie is going through
as you point out like an existential crisis she's
trying to find the nature of her reality her place
in the world and then as they go to you know the
the real world it seems as though she is certainly
being stuffed back into very traditional gender
role boxes and uh Society imposes so I wonder if
it's more just about breaking free and sort of
following your own instincts following your own
voice things like that and carving your own path
because yeah it's like the idea of the Barbie is
that she has been so many things the idea has
been redefined so many times so maybe that's
going to be the sort of thematic thrust I mean
I am curious about how the Ultimate Experience
of the movie will pan out because the teaser
trailers communicated a certain greater sense
of like surreality to the proceedings whereas you
know this takes place obviously in a surreal world
in Barbie World Barbie land whatever you call it
um and then them you know sort of transitioning
out of there into the real world certainly looks
like it'll take us through a bunch of stylized
environments and things like that but it makes me
wonder how much of that surreal nature is actually
going to flavor the movie itself is it going to
bend your mind a little bit at all in a fun way
um but yeah how much of that because you start
with that teaser with the 2001 and everything
and it certainly gives you this CS sort of uh
more meta anarchic sort of quality than than
these subsequent trailers have not that that's a
bad thing well I imagine maybe the first half is
a little more quirky and the second half is when
they get a lot more emotional sure yeah you know
when they're actually stepped into the the real
world circumstances as I I think the part that's
been most appealing about this for a lot of people
has been the strangeness behind this film but even
for them to lead with the marketing of saying for
both camps this movie is not for you oh geez sucks
such an odd Choice I'm not saying they don't know
how I just imagine it's a bit of a challenge to
truly to convey when the whole package is really
gonna feel like I mean I like those kind of movies
as well you know I think one of the first ones I
ever saw was the Johnny Depp brand new film Don
Juan DeMarco of is he really Don Juan DeMarco like
all the all the humans interacting with Johnny WC
really don't want and that's what they're doing
here with Barbie and Ken I don't know how much
that's gonna be part of it because it seems like
they're immediately sold that that is Barbie sure
yeah yeah at least maybe the adults are I don't
know about the kids maybe but I still really like
it a lot it still looks like a lot of fun yeah
and oh yeah it still looks like it has tons of
imagination and and I mean craftsmanship alone
on display lots of enthusiastic Talent yeah
yeah I just feel like we've been doing nothing
but heat tons of praise for this we gotta you
know balance the scales a tad bit here yeah um
yeah kind of get some grapes gotta get some nits
um but I think Margot Robbie's still gonna
absolutely kill it I feel like Ryan Gosling
is still gonna absolutely kill he still looks
absolutely hilarious uh Will Ferrell looks like
he's doing Will Ferrell Lord Business is back
it's crazy to me because I've seen Will Ferrell
really uh you know stretch his legs before
and for this it's like yeah looks like what
Will Ferrell does I hope they're hiding some kind
of other layer or surprise with his character than
just just that yeah but all right guys what did
you think about this trailer leave your thoughts
down below be sure to subscribe leave a like keep
it looking for that podcast last but not least
I sent us for the patron of the day shout out
Ricardo Martinez Ricardo looking through some of
the messages that uh we exchanged with each other
not long ago on our patreon page and I don't know
did you know this he was actually a war vet I did
not know that that is nice that's incredible I
mean that's Iraqi War veteran and it was it's kind
of surprising to me whenever someone uh of who's
contributed to this country and has been willing
to risk their life yeah to do something that I
cannot imagine myself actually going through I
just don't see it in I don't have that I don't
have the kind of character and strength that you
are able to go through with them there's so many
other vets out there as well of who've had to make
that courageous decision and on top of that the
the hardship that comes following you know
posts coming back from a war if you happen
to survive and there's so many vets out
there and we've met other vets who are a
part of the reject Nation as well as yourself
and whenever I meet someone like that I'm like
man you're the you're the ones we really should
be admiring shouts out to all the Vets as well man
um yeah Ricardo thank you so much man even
I you've been nothing but generous and kind
with us this whole time and then learning that
I was like oh damn oh man I didn't realize I
mean we meet a lot of people especially uh who
are part of our patreon and also you know just
subscribers as well who have served in you know
like several branches of the military but very
few have actually you know fought overseas
so to me I'm like wow that is that is very
I can't imagine I just can't imagine what you've
had to deal with especially coming back so shouts
out to you and shouts out to all the Vets who
have been a part of rejection and if you're
not part of reject Nation shouts out to all the
vets in general big respect cannot do what you
guys do alrighty guys well thank you Ricardo
thank you guys for being here see y'all soon